the market jumps 2,000 points scientific
studies show coronavirus hope on the
horizon a new drug is helping patients
and President Trump is calling for
America to reopen by Easter Sunday we
will examine all the excellent news
after weeks of apocalyptic headlines
then the Trump administration announces
the largest stimulus package in American
history will break down conservatives
conflicting emotions on massive
government spending and finally Bernie
Sanders refuses to drop out of the race
and sleepy Joe somehow manages to
deteriorate even further on national
television all that and more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
what a good day it was yesterday you
know it's so funny there was such great
news that came out on the scientific
front on the political front from
President Trump there's a real irony
here which is that when California went
on lockdown
LA went on lockdown a little bit earlier
at the Daily wire they decided okay
they're gonna turn my apartment into a
studio so that we can comply with this
lockdown but my internet was so bad that
they had to wait a little bit you know
and we're just going to the studio I'm
not exactly afraid of this thing so they
are fixing up my apartment in everything
they finally get it ready to go and then
we get this great news president Trump
says he wants to reopen America by
Easter and that's just the tip of the
iceberg President Trump gave a Town Hall
yesterday on Fox News the thing was
great he's really shined in these press
conferences that's I mean as we know
President Trump is basically his own
press secretary this is this is his
superpower you know I mean he's a
reality TV star he just knows how to
work the cameras and so he did this Town
Hall yesterday it really calmed a lot of
fears the market responded during the
Town Hall and he said we are almost
ready to reopen America you know the
allotted two weeks but we'll stay a
little bit longer than that but we want
to get open very soon I think that was a
big reason it's gone up I also think
that the fact that the Senate and the
house we seem to be getting along as
much as you can get along we seem to be
getting along now on a on a bill I think
that maybe had even less of an impact
than the fact that we're opening up this
incredible country because we have to do
that I'd love to have it open by Easter
okay I would love to have it open by you
sir I will I will tell you that right
now I would love to have that it's such
an important day for other reasons but
I'll make it an important day for this
too I would love to have the country
opened up and just raring to go by
Easter this was an absolutely brilliant
announcement for a few different reasons
first reason is the science okay
increasingly the evidence is showing
that this virus this pandemic this
epidemic whatever you want to call it
has been hyped
the media increasingly science is
showing that actually the mortality
rates might be significantly lower than
we think they are will we'll get into
why I mean these are not just crackpot
theories these are coming out of the top
research institutions in the country
that's one reason is as the evidence is
increasingly in favor of let's get
closer to normal let's let's start
bringing things back president rumpus is
able to bring that to the american
people you know he played this pretty
cautiously for the last couple of weeks
now however he's got pretty solid
footing to start to get the economy
going again second reason this was
brilliant is it made news you can hear
it there Bill Hemmer and harris faulkner
are shocked they're the ones
interviewing Trump and they said what
hold on you're saying this is about to
reopen at Easter and they actually kept
going back to that that talking point
throughout the town hall and then later
on the Trump was on Bill Hemmer show
they kept going back to that that was
obviously the news of the day Trump had
that in his pocket so he knew that was
gonna be the big story but the third
reason this is so smart to get this out
here is the symbolism of it we will get
to that in one second first I got to
thank our friends over at Legal Zoom man
you think the economy is a little shaky
right now imagine how it's gonna look
for you if you fall into legal trouble
that is why you've got to check out
Legal Zoom I just speak to this
personally I have used Legal Zoom for
years and years long before the Daily
wire existed on multiple companies they
are who I trust to handle all of my
business legal related needs I think
these guys make it so simple that even
somebody who knows very little about the
workings of business law can can deal
with them they're so so great
LLC's DBAs s corpse I've used them for
LLC's n s corpse they all mean different
things when it comes to paying taxes and
limiting your personal liability there's
a lot to think about
Legal Zoom makes it so you don't need to
worry about doing all the legwork
yourself to find the right answers they
have a ton of resources including their
network of independent attorneys and tax
professionals and since Legal Zoom isn't
a law firm you will save time and money
while avoiding hourly fees you
use the guys that I trust the price is
so unbelievably low and the quality is
so unbelievably high get your business
on the right track for 2020 by visiting
legalzoom.com and use code Knowles Kaena
wles I wonder if I can use my own code
for all the work I you do at Legal Zoom
I want to I'll try to do that save a
little bit of money
that's illegal zoom calm per code
Knowles kena wles Legal Zoom where life
meets legal so president Trump announces
him he wants America to reopen at Easter
smart on the science smart on the news
but the other reason is really smart is
the symbolism of this okay Trump is a
guy who understands the power of symbols
he understands the power of visuals the
guy is a TV star he's been a pop culture
icon for 40 years at this point okay if
President Trump had had done this
interview and Bill Hemmer says okay when
do you think you're gonna try to get
things going again he goes well I think
maybe by April 12th we'll start to get
America back on the right track but no
one would have paid any attention now
Easter is April 12th but that date it's
just like okay well alright so a couple
weeks from now few more than a couple
weeks and then will start to ramp up but
Easter has significance right Easter
carries so much more meaning Easter is a
day associated with joy
you know this nice holiday you spend
with your family Easter is a day
associated with spring springtime is
here certainly by mid-april
that's happier time we're coming out of
winter now and most importantly Easter
is the day associated with resurrection
and right now we have ground our economy
we've grabbed our whole country to a
halt we're locked in our apartments
doing nothing and to have that image
that day of Easter is the day that we
are going to break free we are going to
come back to life that is so significant
there is a strange coincidence here or
Providence maybe that this epidemic has
taken place during Lent it pretty much
began on Ash Wednesday the beginning of
this penitential season of Lent and now
as some of us had predicted it looks as
though President Trump
wants to end it wants to bring us back
to some sense of the normal by Easter
which would be the end of Lent makes a
whole lot of sense for it to end on
Easter would be poetic and it's really
really smart for Trump to bring it out
that way so that that part of the
conference went very well
why why does president from think that
will be able to do this part of it is
our testing has gotten a whole lot
better and so it's not only that our
knowledge of the virus has gotten better
but our testing has gotten better too
dr. Burks who's one of the health
experts on the Trump coronavirus team
also broke this news during the townhall
I just want to speak to the Americans
for just a second though we have to
ensure that we still are testing even
though probably by today we will have
done more tests than South Korea did in
eight weeks in the last eight days in
the last eight days we've done more
testing than South Korea but we did that
because we transform the testing process
as the president spoke to I didn't even
know I just heard the number for the
first time from Debora that in a short
period of time we've done more testing
than South Korea now you're not going to
read that in the newspapers because they
don't like to write things like that but
I'd love you to say that one more time
because that that's a big number we've
done more than South Korea in a short
period of time we're doing more now than
South Korea by a lot that's right we're
doing more than South Korea right now in
the last eight days Trump just knows the
medium right it's the same principle as
to why he announces that he wants to end
this all on Easter is he he says the
newspapers aren't going to report on
this but that's a big number we are
doing so much so we're getting maybe a
little bit conflicting signals right I
actually don't think they're conflicting
but the mainstream press thinks that
they are on the one hand Trump is saying
we're taking this SuperDuper seriously
we're doing so much testing more testing
than South Korea we're sending
ventilators to everybody we're taking
this as seriously as possible also we're
gonna end this thing by Easter are those
conflicting I don't really think so
we'll get into why in in just a moment
this is all great news question is are
we celebrating too soon right we've been
told for weeks now that millions of
Americans are going to die if we
completely shut down the country now
we're being told not as big a deal a
couple more weeks and we'll get this
thing going again which is it well
you've heard on CNN and MSNBC and the
New York Times from every health expert
who says that we're all gonna die
now some health experts are pushing back
on that plane one huge heavyweight in
particular is weighing and this would be
the 2013 Nobel laureate Michael Levitt
Michael Levitt is a Stanford biology
professor a celebrated scientist he is
saying that his models for the corona
virus do not support predictions that
the virus will wreak months or even
years of social disruption or caused
millions of deaths he said what we need
is to control the panic we are going to
be fine okay
very helpful
does he have credibility here yes
Michael Leavitt accurately predicted
what was going on in China so his report
on China said the country would peak in
80 thousand cases and 3,250 deaths what
happened in reality China reported
eighty one thousand five hundred eighty
eight cases with 3281 deaths it gives
you a lot of credibility here he's
saying we're going to be fine we don't
need to panic is it just him no two
other professors of Medicine
coincidentally also at Stanford or
coming out and saying basically the same
things there's an amazing op-ed right
now in the Wall Street Journal though
the headline is is the corona virus as
deadly as they say this is by Aaron Ben
David and j-bot acharya from the top of
the headline it's true that the novel
coronavirus would kill millions without
shelter in place orders and quarantines
then the extraordinary measures being
carried out in cities and states around
the country are surely justified but
there is little evidence to confirm that
premise and projections of the death
toll could plausibly be orders of
magnitude too high
so right if the projections that we're
getting are true then yeah of course we
should lock down and shut down the
country but are the prediction models
true they have a lot of evidence to say
that they're not fear of kovat 19 is
based on high estimates of its case
fatality rate 2% to 4% of people with
confirmed kovat 19 have died according
to the World Health Organization and
others so if a hundred million Americans
get the disease 2 million to 4 million
could die remember that's what we were
told at the beginning of all of this you
want to see 2 million Americans dead you
want to see more than 2 million
Americans dead well if not you got to
shut down the country we believe that
estimate is deeply flawed the true
fatality rate is the portion of those
infected who die not the deaths from
identified positive cases so point
they're making is the point that we've
started to hear a little bit more in the
UK and elsewhere which is that hmm maybe
the number of people who have this virus
is a lot higher than we think it is
because we're just looking at the
percentage of people who get sick and
they're so sick that they go to the
doctor and then they get diagnosed and
then either they recover they don't
recover but what about people who just
you know have mild symptoms like a lot
of young people and don't even get
diagnosed with the virus how many people
have you spoken to who said you know I
think I had that virus about a month and
a half ago I think I told you that I
think I had the virus about a month and
a half ago I don't think that right now
it's possible to test for antibodies
other otherwise I would to see if I had
it in the past but if I did have it I
certainly didn't get diagnosed with it
so I would not be counted among the
people who were infected and therefore
if a lot of people who were infected or
encountered then the mortality rate is
going to be much higher in the reports
than it actually is it says it could
make the difference between an epidemic
that kills 20,000 and one that kills two
million of course I mean if you know it
just depends how many people are in the
denominator right so the the authors
here the Stanford scientists use the the
example of this northeastern Italian
town of Oh near the provincial capital
of Padua so on March 6 every person
involved was tested 33
hundred people they tested the entire
population ninety were positive which
means 2.7 percent of the population was
positive if you apply that prevalence to
the entire population of the province
population there is 955 thousand and
they had 198 reported cases that
suggests that actually it wasn't 198
cases total it was closer to 26,000
infections at the time which is a
hundred thirty fold more than the actual
cases reported now Italy's fatality rate
is 8 percent among those who have been
diagnosed with the virus but if you if
you factor in this possibly much higher
percentage of people who were infected
the fatality rate could be closer to
0.06 percent which is what people were
suggesting in the beginning when they
were making comparisons to the flu
really pleased to see op-eds like this
coming out from people who have some
expertise in this field because so far I
think a lot of public health experts who
have disagreed with the prevailing
alarmist consensus have kept their mouth
shut because we've been told that if you
even suggest that the virus is not as
bad as people say it is that you're
gonna be responsible for deaths and
encouraging people to go out and for
killing people but now you've got the
wall street journal' two major
scientists saying it you had the Yale
scientist come out in the New York Times
just the other day say basically the
same thing you have this Nobel laureate
Michael Leavitt coming out saying
basically the same thing so you're
getting a lot of dissenters on the
scientific side a lot of people saying
calm down and it's not just here in the
US the best scientific news recently is
actually out of the UK so initially the
UK when they were reacting to
coronavirus followed the more
conservative model conservative model
being herd immunity you take the people
who are very at risk immune compromised
for existing conditions over 70 and you
just say stay at home and don't talk to
your grandkids and just quarantine
yourself the rest of us will
we will be in the population will be
doing things and some people will get
the virus the fast fast fast majority a
very small but vast majority will be
fine a very very tiny minority of people
will have complications from this and be
hospitalized but then people will be
immune it will be much harder to pass
this virus along and this is what we've
done for a lot of other public health
issues that was what they were doing
initially then they changed their mind
based on a study out of the UK's
Imperial College now it turns out that
study might be deeply flawed we'll get
to that in a second first I got to thank
our friends over at Ray Khan you know
how much I love ray Khan ray Khan has a
brand new model out the everyday e 25
earbuds they are the best earbuds yet so
you know people are walking around with
their very very overpriced earbuds I'm
not going to use any name this or
anything but they kind of make you look
like druce's they make you look like a
bug
you know those very popular overpriced
ones there there are so many better
options on the market and they just so
happen to come from Ray con ray cons
wireless earbuds are comfortable they're
perfect for on-the-go listening and for
taking phone calls they the sound
quality is superb I've been giving ray
cons to my family members I just love
them they're a tremendous choice they'll
save you some money too and you won't
have to sacrifice quality okay they are
discreet they're much more stylish than
the other options on the market get 15%
off your order today at by rakin comm
slash Knowles that's by rakin comm slash
Knowles for 15% off rake on wireless
earbuds by ray gun comm slash Knowles
canna wles so the UK's free cap was
based on what looks to be a possibly
very flawed study from Imperial College
the Imperial College study predicted
many thousands of deaths even among
young people so you had the Boris
Johnson conservative Tory government
pursuing this herd immunity model where
you're not going to shut down the entire
economy you're just going to quarantine
the people who are at risk then
this study comes out and says actually
even the people that you think are
healthy are not gonna be healthy they're
gonna be in serious trouble
many thousands of young people are gonna
die so Boris Johnson does the only thing
he can do he switches strategy into the
shutdown strategy that we've got here in
the United States now there's a new
study out of Oxford which says much like
these other ones that the death
projections are way off because the same
reason they're significantly under
estimating the number of people in the
UK who already have the virus
this is from the new study professor
Gupta is is the one who is writing this
she writes if the results are confirmed
they imply that fewer than one in 1,000
of those infected with kovat 19 will
become ill enough to need hospital
treatment she's a professor of
theoretical evidence fir'd she led the
study the vast majority develop very
mild systems as the symptoms were no
symptoms at all since a chance you're
walking around with this thing you don't
even know actually speaking of the UK
turns out Prince Charles has been
diagnosed with corona virus and you
think of this as I oh my gosh he's in
the at-risk age group the guy is gonna
die the monarchy's and question the
palace reports he has mild symptoms he's
self quarantining
now some people face serious symptoms
but a lot of people do not Gupta said
I'm surprised that there has been such
an unqualified acceptance of the
Imperial model and that's not just
Imperial colleges fault that's the fault
of all of us and especially political
activists and especially the mainstream
media who have looked consistently to
the most alarming predictions and
accepted those as gospel truth rather
than trying to take a more balanced look
I mean the president from said at this
town hall the other day said or
yesterday he said we've never done this
before
we've never shut down the country over a
public health question we've never shot
down the world economy think about how
many people died from h1n1 flu before we
really did very much of anything about
it but we've reacted much more strongly
to this coronavirus maybe the science
doesn't back that up actually there's
even more good news which is that the
virus is apparently not mutating very
much
now if the virus mutates that means that
drugs you develop to fight the virus are
not going to be as effective at fighting
the virus also if the virus mutates it
means that if you've already gotten it
in your immune that you might not be
immune forever because you'll have a
significantly different virus to fight
off in the future luckily this virus is
not mutating very much which means that
the drugs might work and the immunity
might hold so that's the scientific
front what does this mean for Trump
politically both the virus and the
apparently new response to the virus
some experts are saying Trump is just
experts at putting quotes or saying that
Trump is totally destroying his
political goodwill here I think it's
exactly the opposite we'll get to that
in one second first I got to thank our
friends over at ring rings mission is to
make neighborhoods safer right ring
gives you protection at every single
corner helps you create custom
Affordable security for your home how's
it work rainy detects motion when people
come onto your property and rings video
doorbells let you answer the door and
check in on your home anytime from
anywhere so you could be at home you
could be at the office you could be in
quarantine you could be who knows where
you could be you can check in on your
home I really like this especially when
I'm on the road you know sweet little
ease is a good shot but I like to make
sure that she's safe whether you get a
package delivered or whether some guys
trying to bust in and do you harm you
can check it out and by the way if the
burglar steals your ring it gets
uploaded to the cloud so you won't lose
it get a special offer on the ring
welcome kit right now when you go to
ring calm slash Knolls the welcome kit
includes the ring video doorbell - and
chime Pro it's all you need to start
building custom security for your home
today
ring calm slash an old Skanda wles
that's ring.com / knowles so as more
experts are coming out saying that maybe
we've overreacted Trump has pivoted
back and this is confusing pundits who
think that this is politically
unproductive or counterproductive for
Trump
so initially right Trump says hey let's
not overreact to this thing let's remain
calm let's see what the science says he
had a decent approval rating on the
virus but then the approval ratings
started to fall as all of the stories
about the virus killing millions of
people this started to come out virus
didn't really kill millions of people
but the story is said that the virus
would kill millions of people
so his approval rating drops people
thought he wasn't taking it seriously
enough and then he starts taking it more
seriously and the approval rating goes
up again well okay that's good but now
President Trump is saying maybe we'll be
back open for business by Easter and his
poll numbers are still doing very well
how do you make sense of this Gallup is
showing his approval rating surging 60%
of Americans approve of Trump's handling
to come of combating coronavirus 60%
now that's Gallup you know Gallup isn't
always the friendliest poll to Trump 49
percent overall approve of his job
performance that includes 94 percent of
Republicans 27 percent of Democrats
that's too bad and 60 percent of
independents that's good but what's
important here is the movement so among
Democrats his approval rating has gone
up six points during coronavirus among
independents his approval rating has
gone up eight points during coronavirus
how is that how is this happening people
want a president to take it seriously
but we don't want to shut down the
entire economy and I think Trump is
thinking about one week ahead here so
one week ahead this whole thing really
stops being fun you had last week
massive unemployment claims more
unemployment claims than we saw at the
peak of the 2009 financial crisis we are
going to see that increase and just the
other day
Marriott laid off another many many
thousands of people so many businesses
are laying off people if not going at a
business altogether so Trump is looking
ahead people might have wanted him to
take this virus SuperDuper as seriously
is humanly possible a week ago is that
going to be true a week from now
probably not especially if the new
scientific information that's coming out
all over the globe is accurate they're
not going to want to shut down the
global economy if them if the mortality
rate is as low as 0.06 percent I mean we
don't do that for any other threat to
our lives or safety or health do we we
don't do that for the flu we don't do
that for car accidents this in
particular for some reason the
mainstream media are pushing this we'll
get to why in just a moment the other
way you know that the tide is turning on
coronavirus is that even some
celebrities now are making fun of the
reaction to coronavirus so Ryan Reynolds
very funny Hollywood star he's come out
and he is mocking all of these
self-obsessed slacktivism the hysteria
well thank you prime minister Trudeau we
need to work together to flatten the
curve and fight off kovin 19 I think in
times of crisis I think we all know that
it's it's the it's the celebrities that
we count on most they're the ones who
are gonna get us through this right
after health care workers of course
first responders people work in
essential services ping pong players
mannequins their great childhood
imaginary friends sure like 400 other
types of people look stay at home
practice social distancing wash your
hands we are gonna get through this
thing wring it through this thing
together and I'd like to nominate these
three great Canadians to spread the word
mr. Stephen Paige
constable Terry Reynolds of the Royal
Canadian Mounted Police and mr. Seth
Rogan of the Point grey Rogan's
so this stands in stark contrast to the
imagined video the other day of all
those celebrities some of whom I've
never even seen before singing imagine
it's really sentimental and touchy-feely
and come on guys and Ryan Reynolds comes
out he goes yeah celebrity should shut
up and wash your hands okay
like we'll be fine all right calm down
this is all very promising news even if
we start winding things down by Easter
though that's still over two weeks away
analysts right now predicting 20%
unemployment huge losses are happening
right now the market rebounded a lot
yesterday though right now it's unclear
how the markets reacting so what are we
gonna do in the meantime we're going to
pass the largest economic stimulus
package in history hmm how should
conservatives feel about that we tend
not to love economic stimulus packages
should we get behind this one which is
truly at the largest in history we will
break down what's going on then we'll
get a little bit into the 20/20 ways you
remember the 20/20 race me neither it's
been completely out of the news for a
few weeks and that's been very helpful
to the Democratic 2020 contenders
because the more you see of them the
less you like them maybe maybe that's
their strategy we'll get to all of that
but first got to head on over to Daley
wired.com you know we have launched this
new show all-access live and I say it's
a show and we turn on a webcam that's
what the show is but this is for our
all-access members and during quarantine
we've been making this available to all
of our members because we know you know
you're kind of locked in your apartments
and we want to hang out we're locked in
our apartment you can see welcome to my
humble abode Shea Knowles so it's been a
lot of fun Ben and Jeremy kicked it off
I did one last night we're gonna we're
gonna bring this to you constantly
throughout the coronavirus quarantine
and even afterward we're gonna bring it
but we're only gonna give it them two
all-access members so head on over to
Daley wire.com slash subscribe do that
right now and by the way while you're
there get your mailbag questions and
we'll be doing that tomorrow we'll be
right back in just a moment
we've got the largest stimulus package
ever in the United States history being
passed by a Republican president and
Republican Senate that's unusual that
doesn't usually happen does it
here is president from stop economist
Larry Kudlow announcing the package
yesterday this package will be the
single largest Main Street assistance
program in the history of the United
States the single largest Main Street
assistance program in history United
States phase two delivered the sick
leave for individuals hourly workers
families and so forth
phase three a significant package for
small businesses loan guarantees will be
included we're going to take out
expenses and lost revenues as the
president said eligibility requires
worker retention we will maintain the
people eligible will maintain their
payrolls during this crisis period and
on top of that we will have direct
deposit checks of roughly $3,000 for a
family of four and that will bridge to
enhanced plus dup unemployment insurance
benefits that will essentially take
those up to full wages you know there's
a Yiddish expression which I can't
pronounce because I don't speak Yiddish
but I can give you the English
translation the expression is if you're
gonna eat pork eat it till your mouth
drips if you're gonna eat pork enjoy it
and I think that's what's going on with
a stimulus package Republicans don't
love stimulus packages okay we don't
want to be in the position where we've
got to pass stimulus packages we like
the economy to hum along until three
weeks ago we had the best economy in the
history of the world now Republicans are
forced into this position where we have
to put put a stimulus package out there
because of totally bizarre circumstances
and so there are two ways to do it
either you can do a tepid stimulus
that's very small that's nothing you do
it kind of reluctantly or you can pass
the biggest stimulus package in history
make sure it has some
and if you're gonna eat pork you're
gonna enjoy it this thing is massive
okay
it includes two trillion dollars in
direct assistance and includes another
four trillion dollars in federal reserve
lending power so the overall effect of
the stimulus package is about six
trillion dollars now I guess the silver
lining here is that for four and a half
trillion dollars of the stimulus package
is it lending it's not in just direct
payouts so I guess that's a good thing
still what should conservatives think
about this remember when we hammered
Barack Obama over his stimulus package
in 2009 remember when we hammered him on
that for like ten years now we are
passing a much larger stimulus package
still these are different situations
conservatives should always be skeptical
of these massive government
interventions conservatives should
always be skeptical of direct checks
from the government to the people but
this is fundamentally different from the
2009 financial crisis okay
in the 2009 financial crisis the
financial institutions that got bailed
out were very often responsible for the
crisis in the first place so not all the
time in some cases the government was
responsible for putting financial
institutions in a position where they
had to make decisions that were not very
wise but in other cases these big
financial institutions just knew that
they would get bailed out so it was it
was not a fair market it wasn't it
wasn't a fair gamble it's like it's like
going to a casino and saying you're
gonna play and then if you win money
then you're gonna take the money out of
the casino and if you lose money the
casinos got to pay right that's what
these financial institutions were doing
and so the bailout really irritated a
lot of people this is different here the
people who are getting bailed out or not
to blame at all for what's going on
right now coronavirus is to blame China
is to blame but not the individuals who
are gonna get bailouts and not the
businesses we're gonna get bailouts
these businesses and individuals were
doing just fine and dandy we had the
best economy ever in the history of the
world
and then this damn virus comes out of
communist China and China covered it up
for so many weeks that it spread
throughout the entire world and all of a
sudden the government comes in and says
you got to shut down your business you
can't make any more money you can't
leave your apartment that's not their
fault I mean if the government is gonna
come in and do that and force the
economy to shut down then the government
has some responsibility to make up the
difference here people got to eat you
know people got to live how are we gonna
do that so one possibility for how to
recover from this total shutdown is to
force basically waiters and bartenders
and people who are a little more
vulnerable in the economy than big
bankers to foot the entire bill right
the alternate I mean retail workers
right these are the people who are being
laid off these people are being most
hurt by the crisis to say nothing of the
restaurants and the retail stores so you
can either force them to pick up the
whole brunt of it or we can all pick up
some of the brunt of it and we can all
pick it up through our duly elected
representatives who we put into office
who are passing this bailout package
Kudlow explains this theory here in
pretty simple terms strong workforce
requires strong business you can't have
a job without a business to work for and
hope here is that the companies that are
operating very well at the beginning of
the year when the economy was in good
shape
we will help them and their employees
get through this tough period so they
will come out the other side let's say
this later this spring or summer and
will continue their operations that's
the key point all right I really like
Larry Kudlow and I really like what he's
saying here unlike the Democrat bailouts
in 2009 there's no class warfare here
democrat bill has any of the time right
even as the democrats are passing this
big bailout they're talking about the 1%
and how evil the rich people are and the
financial people larry cudlow is not
doing that he's not vilifying the
business owners on the one hand he's not
vilifying the low-wage workers on the
other hand remember Mitt Romney's 47%
Romney said 47% of
Americans are basically leeches and that
was filmed and probably cost him the
presidency certainly didn't help his
campaign Larry Kudlow is not doing
either of those he's saying hey guys
this thing happened
totally unexpected came out of nowhere
we got to help the workers if we're
gonna help the workers we also have to
help the businesses because you can't be
a worker if you don't have a business
that you can work for he's just calling
it like it is now there's a lot of other
stuff in this bailout as well there are
as tax deferrals for corporations and
individuals I really like that they're
pushing the tax deadline
there's student loan deferrals that's
probably a smart idea especially now if
students aren't able to even go to class
for the next six months or something a
lot of schools have shut down for the
rest of the year they're not coming back
until the fall so it makes sense I think
to defer those student loans do we need
the bailout probably yeah yeah I think
so I mean we we ground the entire
national economy to a halt to
artificially and we can't just let all
of those businesses collapse if this had
been a normal regular part of the
economic cycle then there's a very
strong argument to let things play out
as they will but this was not normal at
all there's nothing normal about
coronavirus the most important takeaway
I think from all of this is we need to
recognize that coronavirus has a cost
okay the days that you've gotten off
from work those have a cost
those don't just come from no we're not
dealing tougher with China in the past
allowing ourselves to get hooked on
cheap Chinese goods and allowing China
to manufacture our medicine for the past
however many years that has a cost okay
open waters has a cost we are now paying
for that cost and the question is who's
going to bear it is it going to be these
waiters and bartenders or are we all
going to bear it probably we're all
going to bear it so overall this was a
great day yesterday for president Trump
great day for the markets it was the
single largest market gain ever market
rose over 2,000 points it's just a great
day for America
now we see the light at the end of the
tunnel we need to turn our attention to
that other minor political matter
perhaps you've forgotten about it the
2020 presidential election
I'm sure you've forgotten about it
because it's been completely out of the
news during coronavirus Joe Biden mostly
has this election locked up doesn't he
and yet Bernie Sanders is going to
remain in the race Bernie could have
dropped out weeks ago but he chose not
to and I told you that he wouldn't drop
out he wouldn't drop out because he's an
ideological candidate this is his last
serious shot at it he could try to run
again when he's 82 no one will take him
seriously now they actually are taking
him seriously the other reason is Joe
Biden is just physically collapsing I
mean the guy is falling apart so Bernie
yesterday well my voice just cracked
maybe I have Khurana virus
Bernie yesterday I get so excited about
2020 he holds his own town hall while
President Trump holds his Town Hall but
Bernie Sanders is not the president
where Sanders is never going to be the
president so Trump's town hall energetic
OnPoint focused made some news funny it
was a really good performance
Bernie Sanders is town hall was not
quite like that here's a quick peek at
Bernie's Town Hall I struggle with
biology in college so that's gonna
manifest itself now but um I can
understand as somebody who has the virus
sneezes in the face of somebody else you
coughed in somebody's face
the virus is transmitted how is it
transmitted if I'm simply in a room
somebody has the virus but it's not
coughing is not sneezing how could it be
transmitted in that situation oh man
give me the virus yeah me put me out of
my misery with this this Town Hall it
was very boring
it was rambling it seemed a little bit
fearful he didn't seem in command of the
room it was not it not a good
performance and yet Bernie's gonna
remain in the race because Joe Biden is
doing somehow even worse Joe Biden was
on ABC he was on the political view
broadcasting when I take it from his
home because I think he's quarantining
himself
because Joe Biden is very much at the at
risk age group he is asked about the
cure and he forms a sentence that made
it seem like he doesn't want a cure for
coronavirus like it'd be better not to
cure coronavirus but really I don't
think you could even decipher what he
meant because it wasn't anything
resembling proper English hot topics we
just about Trump saying the government
would reassess the recommended period
for keeping businesses shut and people
at home are you at all concerned as
Trump said that we cannot let the Cure
be worse than the problem itself we have
to take care of the cure that will make
the problem worse no matter what we have
to take care of the cure that will make
the problem worse no matter what yeah
that's the guy I wanted charged during a
global pandemic yeah the old man it'd be
so much better we'd be handling this so
much better if that guy were in charge
in Joe's defense he probably woke up
five minutes before this interview he
does not this does not look like a guy
who is running for president this does
not look like a guy who's running for
mayor this looks like a guy who's been
retired from politics for a very long
time and barely knows where he is and it
isn't just this one Club it isn't just
the millions of loves we saw before he
kept it up same same topic same time
period same living room and he's
broadcasting from he goes on MSNBC I
almost crawled out of my skin from how
awkward the interview was and now all of
a sudden he is being tough on China he's
making sure and now he's being soft on
his xenophobia in the past so I just I
just can't figure the guy it's like I
don't know it's like watching the yo-yo
I shouldn't have said it that way it's
like watch it that way
that's okay God and the girl on MSNBC is
obviously in the tank for Biden's there
she's she's trying to make this nice and
normal she's oh oh oh yeah no you're
right he's like a yo-yo or what and Joan
knows that that's not a particularly
effective talking point so he stopped it
up no no I shouldn't have said that
what was I what did I mean to say what
what what channel am i on where's my
where am i where am i he has this other
problem in his campaign which obviously
he just seems very old but that puts him
in the position of only reacting to
trump so his whole campaign from the
very beginning was started on this lie
that Donald Trump called Nazis very fine
people at Charlottesville never happened
go to the tape but he started on that
lie he started it
in just pure opposition to Trump there's
no argument to vote for Joe Biden
there's only an argument to vote against
Donald Trump but the politics of
opposition doesn't usually work very
well you know in every presidential
election in recent memory the more
charismatic eras matic candidate has won
has beaten the less charismatic Canada
Trump beat Hillary right Obama beat
Romney Obama beat john mccain george w
bush beat john kerry george w bush beat
Al Gore Bill Clinton beat Bob Dole Bill
Clinton beat George Bush the first so
Joe Biden if he's just nothing if he's
just the absence of Trump he's not going
to fare very well if he even says it in
this interview he says I just I can't
figure the guy he's good I can't write
if you're in the position of trying to
figure or not figure the guy then that
makes you a political pundit that does
not make you the person who is going to
defeat the guy in a presidential
election Joe can't even COFF right he's
not even coughing right and he was doing
an interview on CNN and he coughed
hacked up a lung into his hand and CNN's
Jake Tapper no conservative but Jake
Tapper of all people
actually called a man for it I have not
talked to any individual excuse me you
know you're supposed to coffin to your
elbow I don't know sir thoughts I
learned that actually covering your
white house
you know actually actually that's true
but fortunately I'm alone in my home but
that's okay all right I agree you're
right you should just it's kind of old
school to do it with your hand do it
into the your elbow you're supposed to
do it Jake Tapper won't even let it go
this actually it seems like a minor
point this is actually a pretty telling
comparison here between Joe Biden and
Donald Trump so Joe Biden coughing into
his hand on TV is very similar to Trump
at the press conference on public health
shaking everybody's hand remember that
he said don't shake hands let me shakes
everybody's hand both of them got called
out for it and in Trump's case he owned
up to it he said oh yeah it's a hard
habit to break you're a politician you
shake people's hands but I shouldn't do
it we're all learning not to do it
cool fair enough Joe Biden gets called
out for coughing into his hand egos well
actually it's fine actually it's really
good that I coughed into my hand
actually I'm smart and I'm doing what I
should be doing just say like dude just
say it's it's force of habit and you
didn't mean to do it
Biden's making excuses total Lib move so
of course
Bernie Sanders is not getting out of the
race this is the guy he's running
against and there's a fair chance that
Joe just doesn't have the stamina to
make it to the nomination the left is
furious right now because they've got
this awful candidate for president who
somehow even amidst a serious economic
crisis and a global pandemic still
almost certainly can't be Donald Trump
so they're furious about all the good
news it now seems like it is an active
effort to prolong the coronavirus
epidemic you know the Nevada Governor
Steve sizzle ACK is now banning
hydroxychloroquine which is the only
drug apparently that has shown any
promise of treating coronavirus he's now
banned it for coronavirus patients
anecdotally it hasn't gone through
clinical trials but anecdotally has
helped coronavirus patients but he's
Bandhan based on a bogus excuse that a
guy died from taking the drug but the
guy didn't die from taking the drug a
guy died from taking fish tank cleaner
that happens to have part of the drug in
it along with a lot of other poisons
nonsense but they're banning it I think
because they want to drag this thing out
Democratic governors are now calling for
weeks and weeks and months and months
more shutdowns even if that is not
necessary even in the opinion of the
public health experts why because they
want to keep this economy shut down
through November so it helps them
politically Nancy Pelosi did her damned
best to stop relief for the coronavirus
she did as best she could to torpedo the
stimulus bill wide emma-crats love
stimulus bills they love government
spending they love direct checks to
Americans right doesn't matter because
she knows it's gonna help and so she
wants to prolong the misery okay that's
fine they can try to get that political
advantage unfortunately for them the
good news is apparently right around the
corner we've already gotten a little bit
of it and it looks like the future is
promising so let's bring it on and let's
hope that it continues all the way until
Easter get your mailbag questions and
I'll see you tomorrow
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knoll Joe
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director Havel
without ski editor and associate
producer Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Nika Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clifford
[Music]